[Music]
this morning we're exploring an issue at
the center of the national political
debate the disturbing rise in murders in
many big cities
a recent study found homicide is up 37
in 20 u.s cities in chicago at least 497
people have been killed so far this year
that's according to the chicago's
tribune homicide tracker
that's already 145 more than last year
errol barnett looks at what may be
behind the rise in all these homicides
what have the past few months been like
for you
a tragic couple of months pastor donovan
price doesn't need statistics to tell
him
violence in chicago is up since the
pandemic began
you see he goes to crime scenes in his
underserved community to comfort
shattered families
often victims of random violence in your
view
why are things apparently getting worse
there's a lot of things that perhaps are
coming to head we were living in a war
zone before the pandemic
and so a pandemic on top of a war zone
on top of
of systemic issues is of course
a problem on top of a problem if we do
nothing
it seems to me we're in for several more
months
of elevated violence criminologist
richard rosenfeld is a professor at the
university of missouri st
louis he and his team recently released
this study on covert 19 and crime
it analyzed 11 criminal offenses in 27
cities and found during the pandemic
domestic violence and aggravated assault
rose
and homicides spiked 37 percent
from may to june with the most dramatic
increases in chicago
philadelphia and milwaukee in july the
chicago tribune reported at least
107 people were killed making it the
most
violent month there in nearly three
decades
one now has to speculate about why we
see
those increases it could be because
of the impact of the pandemic on police
activity
and also one has to consider the fact
that in many cities the police were
redeployed from their normal patrols to
address
protest activity
in late may protests began nationwide
against police brutality
following the death of george floyd
protests recently erupted in kenosha
wisconsin
over the police shooting of jacob blake
a recent poll found confidence in law
enforcement has hit a record low
u.s attorney general bill barr recently
tried to blame the crime uptick
on some protesters demands to defund the
police
i think it also is related to the
efforts that we've recently seen to
demonize
police and to defund their work the nypd
is
moving officers where they're needed
engaging with the community more deeply
to fight crime
increasing gun arrests in new york city
homicides in the last
month are up 50 percent compared to the
same time last year
and 34 year-to-date with 280 murders
so far in 2020. i think it's something
that we've ignored for a long time
gangs but the real problem in america
lies in handguns eric adams is the
brooklyn borough president and a former
nypd captain
he's calling for a multi-state gun task
force to address the violence
do we ask our police officers in general
to do too much
yes we do no matter what happens we
immediately want to call the police to
handle it
that is not the form of policing that we
need
we need to have greater crisis
management teams we need to have young
people be involved
in dealing with low-level nuisances
and then our faith-based institution we
must become more proactive
back in chicago pastor donovan is
grappling with the most
innocent victims of crime children this
is where it came out
that's where the bullet exited her body
out of the front and it entered through
her back
wow on june 30th pastor donovan was
there
minutes after three-year-old diana was
shot in her back
while playing outside her home diana
survived but no one has been arrested
for her shooting
deidre taylor is her mother do you
remember that day
you remember you got shot
what do you remember about how that felt
and what was happening around you
outside what would you say to people who
hear about these shootings
i was saying you're serious
it's no joke it's important to know that
more than a bullet gets penetrated
lives get penetrated and in this world
in this city
either part of the problem or you're
part of the solution right now
there's there's no in between for cbs
this morning
errol barnett new york
pastor donovan said something very
interesting there it's more than a
bullet that penetrates i know this a
three-year-old child should never be
asked
do you remember the day you got shot